Bienvenidos a este especial de economía
Yo Soy Daniela Blandón vamos a analizar
los principales hechos que impactaron
nuestros bolsillos en el 2022 me
acompaña Por supuesto mi equipo
económico de aquí en France 24 estoy con
Juan Pablo lucumí Daniel aureño de
sorpresas de pérdidas y también de
ganancias ya lo veremos y con Jorge
Hurtado la Jorge qué tal muchachos gusto
saludarlos y bueno sin duda fue un año
emocionante para los mercados bursátiles
bastante emocionante pero yo diría que y
Ustedes deben estar de acuerdo en que si
el 2022 económico pudiera resumirse en
una sola palabra esa sería la inflación
Y es que si nos vamos a las cifras como
tal desde Egipto pasando por Turquía o
inclusive Líbano que atraviesa por una
difícil crisis económica hasta en la
principal economía europea que es
Alemania o si aterrizáramos en América
en Estados Unidos y llegáramos hasta
Argentina en cualquiera de todos estos
lugares el alza de los precios de la
canasta familiar en el último año ha
superado sus niveles más altos en
décadas la razón las constantes
interrupciones en la cadena mundial de
suministro que ya venían de la pandemia
y alimentadas por la invasión rusa en
Ucrania que también se sintió a miles de
kilómetros Como por ejemplo aquí en
América Latina como lo vamos a ver
miren un puesto de jugo de naranjas en
pleno corazón turístico de Bogotá ha
sido por años sustento suficiente para
esta madre soltera de cuatro hijos llegó
a las seis de la mañana pero por primera
vez Diana Pérez ha tenido que recurrir a
los prestamistas informales también
conocidos Como Gota a gota para poder
llevar comida a su mesa eso ya usted le
prestan 100 y tiene que pagar 120 Y si
usted se atrasa tiene un problema al
verraco ya La amenaza anito llegó
situación como muchos colombianos
víctima de una inflación desenfrenada
estos vasos estaban a 2.200 y ahora
están a 3.500
la miel
está bien está a 7000 el mero macho
estaba a 12.000 y ya está a 25,000 como
ella son los millones que viven bajo la
línea de pobreza Quienes más han sufrido
las consecuencias del alza mundial de
los precios una situación que ha tomado
por sorpresa Hasta los más acostumbrados
a lidiar con la inflación en este
mercado de Buenos Aires a Carlos
príncipe le llaman el rey de la molleja
desde los 13 años heredó un negocio de
más de un siglo de tradición en su
familia yo no tuve nada más que sin
inflación 10 años que fue la década del
90 después siempre tuvo inflación en
Argentina donde la variación anual de
precios ronda el
90%, la carne no ha subido al mismo
ritmo pero sí ha golpeado los bolsillos
a su manera la carne Me aumentó un 50%
yo el aumento un 50% Pero qué pasa los
otros artículos subieron el 100 y el 150
por ciento bolsita bandeja mano de obra
a miles de kilómetros en Norteamérica
más personas han salido perjudicadas de
un fenómeno inflacionario que no conoce
fronteras y que no solo toca
consumidores
luddica Flores no solía terminar el día
sin atender a seis o siete clientes en
su centro de estética en Nueva York
están los lunes son Realmente súper
quietos realmente pues ahora sí que no
la pasamos sentadas Y eso o sea si nos
ha afectado bastante Hay días que o sea
lunes martes y miércoles que tú dices
súper quieto tres economías distintas y
un Común denominador los efectos tardíos
de la pandemia y la guerra en Ucrania
llevaron a una pérdida de poder
adquisitivo que no se veía en décadas y
parecen haber llegado para quedarse
Bueno ahora todos estamos de acuerdo en
que 2020 y 2021 estuvieron marcados por
la pandemia del covid 19 en 2022 la
agenda la dominó la guerra en Ucrania
Jorge sin duda alguna Y es que este
conflicto de la guerra en Ucrania
reconfiguró todo el suministro
principalmente para Europa para darnos
una idea antes de este conflicto el 75%
de las exportaciones de gas Ruso y el
55% de las de petróleo se dirigían hacia
Europa Europa impuso ahora un precio
tope a la compra de petróleo ruso como
respuesta a la invasión mientras Moscú
limitó los envíos de gas ruso hacia el
viejo continente a casi cero los
analistas ahora calculan que la crisis
se prolongará durante años y que esta
situación energética le costará a Europa
varios puntos de su producto interno
bruto Cómo cambió si el escenario en los
últimos meses y qué proveedores ganaron
nuevos mercados se lo preguntamos el
economista Daniela calle esto nos dijo
los grandes ganadores de la Guerra de
Ucrania en términos éticos son
claramente Estados Unidos
Qatar Dubai
lo principalmente los grandes
suministradores de gas natural licuado
para el mundo no
si podemos hablar de ganadores en
cualquier caso los grandes perdedores
siguen siendo los países de la Unión
Europea porque estamos hablando de
parches lo que se ha hecho en la Unión
Europea ha sido evitar un corte de
suministro evitar una crisis mucho mayor
pero la crisis energética de la Unión
Europea viene de haber tomado decisiones
equivocadas el cierre de las de las
centrales nucleares
prohibir la producción doméstica de gas
natural prohibir la producción doméstica
de litio etcétera y dejar una política
energética que está diseñada
fundamentalmente por políticos y no por
orientadas a la industria Entonces el
problema energético de la Unión Europea
se mantiene y yo creo que es
una podemos decir que es un uno de los
actores perdedores de esta de esta
situación pero perdedor por una por un
problema energético que ya existía antes
de la pandemia el año 2019
bueno la guerra en Ucrania también
supone un duro golpe para la seguridad
alimentaria esto principalmente porque
Rusia y Ucrania son dos superpotencias
agrícolas que eran responsables del 30%
de El de la exportación o del comercio
mundial de trigo y del 78% de las
exportaciones de aceite de girasol tras
la guerra la factura mundial de
importación de alimentos se elevaría a
uno coma 94 billones de dólares esto es
un alza del 10% respecto a 2021 y esto
debido al aumento de los precios según
estimaciones de la FAO A qué países
golpearía más esta crisis se lo
preguntamos a nuestro invitado
los grandes perjudicados por la invasión
de Ucrania en cuanto a su ministro y en
cuanto a precio son sobre todo los
países del norte de África que dependen
hasta en un 80% de el suministro de
grano por parte de Ucrania
también obviamente impacta a todos los
países que tienen una fuerte
cantidad y un porcentaje importante de
su producto en la agricultura como son
muchos países latinoamericanos que
necesitan de ese grano para la ganadería
y para la agricultura pero lo que es
cierto es que ese
ese cambio de percepción de riesgo que
ha habido que ha generado que el precio
de los alimentos mundial ya
en diciembre de 2022
estén en negativo con respecto a enero
del año
a pesar de haber subido mucho entre
febrero y junio también nos demuestra
que esas cadenas de suministro están
mucho mejor de lo que se estimaba pero
el problema de la cosecha de
2022 va a ser un problema que va a
seguir
digamos generando tensiones de Cara a la
primera parte y del año
este año también tuvo noticias
empresariales y la más sonada sin duda
alguna fue la compra de Twitter por
parte del multimillonario y long musk
una historia que nos va a contar Juan
Pablo Así es Y ya la veremos porque todo
empezó con como si se tratara de una
broma en diciembre de 2017 cuando
moscteó amo Twitter un usuario le
respondió deberías comprarlo y luego el
excéntrico dueño de tesla preguntó su
precio desde ahí ya para el 5 de abril
de 2022 hizo una encuesta sobre si
querían un botón de edición de tweets en
una primera señal de querer tener el
control de la red social el 14 de abril
hace una oferta oficial y después de
varios intentos convenció a sus
directivos pero la historia vendría a
cambiar drásticamente tres meses después
Así es Daniela el 8 de julio en esta
fecha
mosc Cancela su oferta en gran medida
porque desconfiaba de los datos sobre la
cantidad de cuentas falsas Twitter no se
queda de brazos cruzados y cuatro días
más tarde demandó al hombre más rico del
mundo por haber retirado su oferta los
tres meses siguientes fueron muy
intensos luego de varios llamados del
tribunal de Delaware que tramitaba la
demanda en octubre
mosc accedió al contrato original de
compra por 44 mil millones de dólares
pero no fue Sino hasta el 27 de ese
mismo mes un día antes de la fecha
límite que la juez le había dado para
tomar una decisión que el dueño de tesla
dio la última palabra para sellar el
acuerdo finalmente hemos se convirtió en
el ceo de la compañía y lo primero que
hizo fue despedir a los antiguos
directivos toda una novela pero en
resumen qué datos si nos vamos a las
cifras Twitter ha perdido un millón de
usuarios esto Pues también teniendo en
cuenta la cifra de los 44 mil millones
de dólares que acabamos de mencionar
también pues se le obligó a los
internautas que quieren ser verificados
va a tener una mensualidad de 8 dólares
y otro de los datos es que el 50% de la
fuerza laboral fue despedido es decir
3.700 empleados bueno sabemos que no ha
sido un buen año para las tecnológicas
Juan Pablo Así es Daniela si nos vamos
para este 2022 dejó grandes ganadores y
perdedores como perdedores las que
habían sacado el jugo de la pandemia
como meta matriz de Facebook Instagram y
WhatsApp Y también Amazon Netflix o
Spotify que tuvieron que recortar de
forma masiva su plantilla de
trabajadores y que perdieron millones de
usuarios después del boom pandémico
ahora si nos vamos a las grandes
ganadoras fueron definitivamente Y eso
creo que los tres Estamos de acuerdo las
petroleras por el incremento de los
precios a nivel mundial por la guerra en
Ucrania y no podemos despedirnos de este
especial sin la cifra del año
3,35 billones de dólares Este es el
producto interno bruto de 2021 de
California Porque es importante este
Jorge Bueno es importante porque está a
punto de superar a Alemania como la
cuarta Economía del mundo eso según un
reciente análisis de bloomberg que dice
que mientras Alemania o la economía
germana está en retroceso debido a todos
los factores que antes mencionábamos en
este mismo programa Pues el estado más
poblado de Estados Unidos avanza hacia
esta cifras récord así es y de esta
manera como lo estamos diciendo si
California fuera un país que daría solo
por debajo de Estados Unidos China y
Japón impresionante definitivamente Así
es pues a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía ustedes dos Muchas gracias por
todo su trabajo durante 2022 y nos vemos
también en 2023 con muchas más noticias
económicas aquí en France 24
[Música]